all right our first headline is from
Connecticut baseball just starting up
there in the police in Ridgefield
Connecticut are investigating a fire in
which 25 gallons of gasoline were doused
onto a baseball field by someone who
thought that was the best way to dry out
the field in after heavy rain so it
rained it rained before a little league
game the who was it was the manager of
one of the teams I was like the home
team manager it's unclear that's but
somebody was like all dry police are
investigating some was like I'll draw
the field so these kids can play ball
and then just let the infield on fire
use anything how many gallons of
gasoline 50 gallons and you know with
that amount of firepower there they lost
you know they lost a little bit of
control of it it's not I mean I haven't
they've used helicopters in the past to
try to drive a field doesn't really work
Erica do we have a video of that little
league game where they try to drive the
field with the gasoline
I mean yeah I mean you think they would
have went at what point did they call it
they canceled the game there's no games
being played fifty could cost up to
fifty thousand dollars I think it's
another reminder those kids just want to
play a game right it's another house
they're in this situation we didn't have
these problems in California like our
fires are natural and they're in the
hills we don't have to worry about you
know rain on a baseball field that you
have to dry out for fire is another
reason like the longer I live here the
more insane it seems that anyone lives
in the Northeast I'm just glad that this
is that this was a baseball you know
this happen in a baseball game in a
football game because there's so many
more players in the football team you
know I mean like if you listen to that
clip you hear 18 20 kids you know having
a hard time play played again yeah you
know I mean that's like they're in the
dugout they're they're worried you know
I think most of them got out with minor
injuries smoke inhalation will follow
them forever but I think that if it'd
been football players that it would have
been you know melted helmets and stuff
like that you don't need that and these
kids you know I just hope they get a
chance to make up the game and and and
some adults moving forward find a better
way to dry the field and I'm burning a
bunch of kids to death our last
headlines from the great countries my
favorites yeah you know it's the
Anthony's favor because it goes last the
the great country of Brazil where a
judge this week ordered that a pair of
identical twins both pay child support
to a woman who was seeking a paternity
results because neither one of them will
admit to being the father they are
identical twins and she knows that she
slept with one of them the paternity
test for one of the guys turned up
positive but they made his identical
brother also
take a test and that also came up
positive and now they both have to pay
child support and she's saying that she
doesn't know which brother she slept
with how would she know I mean they're
identical twins I'm sure their names are
different you know what I mean like I
don't know I I assume there's more to
the story that she slept with both guys
she's some of both twins at certain
points maybe one of the twins was like
hashed up with this girl now's your
chance do you know I mean I don't know
how to twins work well they both they
both denied the first guy denied he was
the father even though the paternity
test came back and so that's why they
made the identical twin brother do it as
well but there is even there is more to
the story the judge in the case who was
livid said it was it evident that the
defendants from adolescence took
advantage and continued to take
advantage of the fact that they're
identical twins it became clear that
they have repeatedly used each other's
name to attract as many women as
possible and to hide instances of
betrayal in their relationship so this
is like a long con that they do with
lots of women if the judge says that
about two people why did why wouldn't
they killed on the spot like if they're
that if they're that what's the word
insidious with their twin behavior you
got to put them in separate prisons or
you got to kill them on the spot or mark
one of their faces you know I mean with
like a like a brand you know it just
says like twin well it'd work it's kind
of I mean I wouldn't say it's really
working out cuz it took a while to go
through courts and they're gonna kill it
now the kids nine years old they are not
splitting that's kind of the the twist
is they're both pain equal they're both
things like as much like the maximum
right which is depressingly only $60
each a month but apparently that's
that's you know above what you would
expect for minimum wage which is what
they make in Brazil so she's actually
getting double what she would have
gotten from either one of them look if
one of them had just said I'm the father
then that then they could have split it
and they would have they would have been
paying half but instead they're paying
double but what's to stop one of the
twins from coming
and being like here's your $60 and then
she goes to the other twenty is like
what do you mean I just gave it to you
you know I mean this could go on forever
you got a brand their faces mm-hmm you
got a brand their faces and this kid's
nine years old well now yeah the girl is
now nine years old it took forever to go
through courts and all sorts of
different things there any visitation I
don't think there - I don't think
they're too interested it is you know
it's kind of like a sad reality of you
know I had did you have any friends that
were twins two of my best friends were
twins there were two sets of twins the
Nelson brothers and the McBride brothers
shout out to the v-tex to the best
people I've ever known who weren't
identical but everyone thought they were
identical except for their friends or
the people that really knew him that
could definitely tell the difference and
that's the type of thing in high school
- everyone talks about it's like Oh Bob
you know how why don't you go do this
and that and like you know say you're
Jeff - to a girl and then Lisa you know
they like everyone's always pushing
twins to go in this direction - they did
twins are screwed up like I think we
should go back to you know back in the
day if someone had twins and they were
identical they would throw them off a
cliff Carrie Game of Thrones style you
don't see a lot of twins on Game of
Thrones
of course you know the vampire twins
from the Matrix Reloaded those are two
of the worst people ever not a twin guy
and the twins the twins in my high
school the twins in my high school I
remember their parents wouldn't let them
do things without like each other
they're like what if something happens
to one of you we want the other one to
be there I think they had to go to
college together - my friends went to
college together the v-tex ice I if I if
you're identical twins
I assume you're flat-out rapist please I
mean you could look at this for me give
me one example clean I'll believe it
when I see it
yeah you could look at this because -
easy in so many cases - tempting in so
many capsules power corrupts absolutely
what's that documentary three brothers
three identical twin three identical
strangers in and there's so many cases
and I'm thinking of this with with my
friends who are totally different like
what you know totally different in terms
of their personality the lives that they
led the types of people
you know the day all that sort of stuff
you know that happens all the time with
twins but you could look at this story
as like they're in it to win it the you
know did they've stayed like buddies
this whole time with this scheme like
they they're very similar like they're
they're close but they're still making
minimum wage in Brazil which is not like
at the height of success I'll tell you
this right now if I had a twin brother
I'd kill him I wouldn't risk I wouldn't
risk the temptation taking over I would
kill my I would kill my twin brother
wouldn't you I feel like you would be
attracted to him though
of course of course I would go crazy
he's my brother I'm not blind you know
what I mean it would just drive you
crazy to have this other guy it's one of
the reasons I would have to kill you
know I mean so I wouldn't HUS so I
wouldn't I wouldn't sleep with my my
twin brother it would really be an
amazing thing my I would never sleep
with my brother my actual brother yeah
there's a seven year age gap but twin
brother and nothing wrong with that and
that's but I would have to kill
[Music]
you